it was sickening it was absolutely i
physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized by it wanda sykes isn't
holding her thoughts back on the oscar
slap heard around to the world
oh wow on wednesday the 58 year old
comedian who co-hosted hollywood's
biggest night alongside regina hall and
amy schumer stopped by ellen and gave
her two cents on will smith slapping
chris rock across the face live on air
oh wow
wow
will smith just smacked out of me
lit my
the incident went down after chris made
this joke about will's wife jada pinkett
smith jaina i love you g.i jane 2 can't
wait to see it all right
and wanda she says she missed the big
smackdown but she was there in time to
hear the king richard star's outburst
that followed will just starts cursing
you know from his seat keep your white
my wife's name whatever and
and i just was like what what is is this
really happening and
and then someone showed me on the video
i was like yeah he smacked chris
and i just felt so awful for my my
friend you know chris and uh
and it was it was sickening it was
absolutely i physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized by it me too not only was
the monster-in-law star sickened by the
whole thing she thinks will should have
been escorted out of the building yeah
because it
and for them
to
let him stay in that room
and enjoy the rest of the show and
accept his award i was like how gross is
this this is just the wrong message you
know like you assault somebody you get
escorted out the building
and
that's it you know uh but but for them
to let him continue i thought i thought
it was was gross on monday will issued a
public apology to chris on instagram
writing that he was out of line and
wrong quote i am embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be there is no place for
violence in a world of love and kindness
i know he
he apologized to chris but
um i believe that you know we were the
hosts
right so we were the this is our house
we're inviting you in we're hosting
we're keeping we're going to take care
of y'all tonight make sure you have a
good time and no one has apologized to
us and we worked really hard to put that
show together e.t was with wanda's
co-host before the big show and they
dished on all that hard work getting to
do this with regina and wanda they are
such heroes of mine they are comedy
royalty we've been having so much fun
the
preparation has been the most fun i've
enjoyed every second of getting ready
with these ladies i am so excited
and we've been really working it's
wonderful it's scary too you know it's
intimidating it's exciting
it's every emotion you would expect to
have because there's um there's so many
eyes on it and while will may not have
said sorry to wanda regina and amy wanda
revealed that chris has
you know i i saw chris you know at ed
guy's party and uh and as soon as i
walked up to him the first thing he said
was i'm so sorry and i'm like why are
you apologizing he's like it was
supposed to be your night it was
supposed to you and amy and regina you
all were doing such a great job i'm so
sorry this is now going to be about this
because that's you mean that's who chris
is